on today's show we talk about choosing
life after trauma
and we talk to two women about how to
know when their relationship
is over stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up good folks this is john
and
i'm john and this is the dr john dalone
show the show i named after myself
because why not i didn't name it after
myself
every time i don't know why i have to
address it every time drives me crazy
every time
but i'm glad you're with us we are
having a blast
if you have seen lately the folks tuning
into this show
has more than tripled from 17 what's 17
times three
is that for i don't know a lot
a lot of people 17 times seven um
51 oh my 51 peop really
zach just did that on his calculator on
a cell phone that was good two thumbs up
that was good zach
so thank you so much for joining us hey
listen um if you want to be on this show
we're going to talk about mental health
relationships life anything everything
all of it
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-6933
and if you don't have access to a
telephone that'd be weird to call into
the show but you can find one later but
if you want to do it on the internets go
to
uh johndaloni.com show fill out the form
and it will go to kelly
so listen i want to do something fun
this morning i got a note
via instagram that from somebody that
said
their husband was nine years sober today
and wanted to know if i'd give him a
shout out on the show
and i said hey let's do one better why
don't you give me his number
and we'll just call him so i was gonna
call him just walking around
out in the neighborhood while i was
going for a walk this afternoon and then
we thought no let's just call him right
here on the show
so we're gonna ambush him and see if
this works he has no idea we're calling
and his name is james and hopefully we
don't do all this and he doesn't say
you can't use this on the air all right
so here we go we're going to give it a
shot
james hey this is john from the dr john
delaney show dude what are you doing
that's crazy uh i'm mowing grass
listening to your show
actually you're mowing grass
yeah that's i run a lawn business in the
atlanta area
dude what a baller man well hey listen
your wife reached out and said today's a
big day for you brother and she want to
know if i'd give you a shout out
and i said hey let's just do one better
let's just call him so
tell me what you're celebrating today uh
nine years uh sober nine
years sober man congratulations dude if
we had like uh
cannons and confetti we would blow them
off but we don't have any of that stuff
so i'll just clap for you
something like that man congratulations
dude and so what are you doing these
days you're running a lawn business in
atlanta area
yeah so uh my wife and i we just got
married last year
um and are having a baby whoa
dude congratulations man yeah so i was a
happy wedding present
um and she works in the recovery field
and i
i run a lawn business here in atlanta
man congratulations all right so what
would you say
the key to staying sober nine years is
because that's a that's i mean it's
basically almost a decade right that's a
huge accomplishment
what get give us uh give the listeners
here
what what is uh a key to staying sober
for 90 years
uh for sure taking it one day at a time
like whenever i first got sober
i couldn't imagine being sober for this
long like it blows my mind it's really
truly a miracle
i mean it's amazing um
so but taking it one day at a time you
know is
is the key because i can i can do
anything for a day or for a minute or
for an hour
you know well man hey listen i'mma let
you get back to moen
taking it one day at a time that's what
i'm doing as i stumble through trying to
be on the radio and run a podcast
and i'm terrible at it you i'm trying to
say that
you are absolutely amazing man like you
are so funny and i love listening to you
guys i think that you're an
incredible addition i value you guys so
much i mean y'all don't even know
how much you inspire some random uh
georgia boy to keep going another day
so well listen i've been stumbling
through this for a little over a year
and you've been taking it day by day for
a decade so
you inspire me and i'm grateful for you
man and uh
hug that wife years and you get home
that little baby of yours
and um mode to the best of your
abilities i don't know what you're
supposed to say there so
mo mo awesome today brother and i will
um
i will talk to you soon all right man
congratulations james thank you so
thank you so much for the call all right
brother have a good one appreciate it
nine years man what a stud
james way to go hey listen if you uh
want us to do shout outs we've never
done one of those before we're just
making this up on the fly because why
not the show's got my name in it
um shoot kelly an email at
ask john uh no no john delaney.com
show how about that um and put a note in
there and we will see if we can do shout
outs
i think that's awesome good for that guy
that would have been way cooler if he
had
started swearing real life gotcha gone
bananas being like hold on
um i'm beating this guy up on the side
of the road or something but james is a
good guy so he said he was listening to
our show when you called him like that's
pretty meta
yeah that's kind of super metal like
we're in the matrix for sure
it's all a simulation man all right um
so let's go straight back to oh well
let's just say let's go straight to the
phones we just got off them but let's
talk to
callers that actually called in let's go
to alicia in asheville north carolina
alicia what's going on hey there how are
you doing today
i'm good how about you doing good i
have a question obviously so i
am divorced and me and my husband
co-parent very well
together and recently he's basically
been living in my third bedroom
which is good for the girls and
everything but
i feel like they get more time with him
um but i feel like i need to create
boundaries
with it like between us because it is my
home yes
um oh on how to do that
it's kind of like um we eat taco bell
three times a day
every day for a year and i think that i
probably should start eating better
that's kind of what you're asking me so
do you have your uh um how long y'all
been divorced
um we have been divorced for over a year
we were legally separated for
two years before we got divorced okay so
y'all haven't been together for three
years
we will he was still living with me when
we were separated
it's a very strange situation but he was
still living with me
we ended up getting divorced he moved
out and then it's just kind of like been
a transition of him
being more present why
why did you get separated and then
divorced but stay roommates
um for the girls and like i feel like a
part of us was trying to work on the
relationship but
which part of which part of us the u
part um
yes yes um
but ultimately is because it just gave
him more accessibility to our children
like he just it allows him to have more
time with them
um is this a way for
you to keep him in your life yes
absolutely
okay and if he had to go find his own
place to live would he disappear
um no he wouldn't just fear i'd still
see him i mean
it would it would just be different i've
lived with him pretty much my entire
adult life so it's a strange thing
like when he's not there if i guess i
could say yes and
are you willing to cash in on any future
romantic relationships any future growth
any future movement you're going to have
any semblance of a healthy relationship
model for your kids
in order to keep things the way they've
been forever
yeah and that's what i think about
because it's like this isn't how this
isn't the example i want to set and just
kind of
i don't know where to go from there yeah
it is it's example i love your heart but
it is the example you are setting right
yeah yeah um when's the last time you
all slept together
um yeah okay
so what does
what does divorce even mean
it sounds like y'all are dating and
you're honestly just sounds like a mess
yes it's yeah i mean i think the divorce
part was just
like the legality of well we're no
longer legally combined
um so it's like in theory there's the
freedom to go
date and do these things it just doesn't
happen
does he date around nothing i'm aware of
i know he has like when we were
separated but not that i know of
recently
oh man okay so
yeah you got to get them out of your
house and you've got to move on with
your life
and what's happening is how old are you
are your daughters
they are they're three they're twins and
three old twins okay
um you either need to decide this is
gonna be the guy you're with and he's
gonna decide
that you or the woman he's with um
or you are dancing with something where
he's gonna come home one day
and have been dating somebody for six
months and you didn't know it
or he's gonna come home and have
something real serious
or you're gonna run into something real
serious or he's gonna get transferred
out or he's going to get tired of just
being with the kids and he's just going
to move
or you're going to get a job opportunity
or get transferred to some other
whatever is going to happen and all you
are doing right now
is um you know when you like
uh i'm just projecting out here but when
you first realize we're about to get
divorced
and that extra that fourth fifth and
sixth beer made all that go away for an
evening and then you had to deal with it
tomorrow
that's what y'all are doing right now
yes and the difference
is you're dragging two three-year-olds
along here
and not i guarantee i trust holy that
y'all
um are doing well co-parenting
but you're playing house and your kids
are gonna pick up on that
tension on those comments on that gap
between you two
and they're gonna think that is how
normal functioning healthy adult
relationships work
where two divorced people live in the
same house date other people one just
dates
the other but the other dates other
people and then make sure everybody know
all you know what i mean
there's no yeah there's no romance
there's no dates they're not seeing how
somebody who
loves their mama treats their mama how
mama
treats dad they're not seeing any of
that they're just seeing two roommates
who occasionally hook up
and by the way kids can feel that and
that awkwardness the next day
all of that they're absorbing it
why are you terrified to leave him do
you still love him
i do yes i think this part of me will
always love him but that
doesn't mean i should be with him i
guess okay so why i
i 100 honor that right and i think
you're right i think there'll always be
a party who cares about this guy no
question about it
um if he asked you to marry him today he
just came home this evening and said
what are we doing let's get married
would you say yes
truthfully i don't know why not because
i think about because i have those
moments where i miss like the romantic
relationship but i think about like
there's a reason why we're
not together like there's a reason why
and why not divorce
why'd you get divorced um
ultimately i had an affair years ago and
we never recovered from it
and there was just forever like anger
and tension towards each other
and we just never really recovered i
mean we get i mean we get along well
but it's like when it comes to the
romantic part it's like it just changed
and it's like we fought
we fought a lot so you deserve to have
somebody who will forgive you
in your life and love you for who you
are mistakes and all
and if that's not this person you need
to move on
okay you gotta move on you screwed up
years ago yep
you did and yeah the more you carry that
around with you
and the more that um he weaponizes that
and uses that as reason to not
either fully love you or fully move on
all it's just a mess
right and what i'm telling you is this
only gets
this only ends badly it doesn't end well
because y'all are sitting on top of an
unhealed wound
that he has chosen and it's to some
degree you have chosen to never heal
from
and it's gonna eventually erupt
and that's a gross analogy i know
because i don't want to talk about
erupting wounds
but it's coming your way and the mess
from all of that the pus and the blood
and the infections gonna get all of your
daughters
don't do that to them and don't do that
to yourself
right yeah that's is that fair
yeah it is fair it's just uh
scary i guess to think about sometimes
but yes it is fair do you think you're
worthy of being loved
yes yeah i would like to think so no no
no do you think so
yes you are are you are you a forever
are you a cheater for the rest of your
life no not at all
did you screw up once yes absolutely and
it's
okay here's what learn from that here's
what i want you to do
i want you to take out a piece of paper
and i want you to write cheater on it
with a marker
okay and then i want you to fold it up
in an envelope
and i want you to mail it to me
and when you mail it you're done with it
you're done okay you're finished you can
do that okay you can look up my address
on the website i want you to mail it to
me
you're done with it okay and
you have to move on you have to forgive
yourself you've got to put that thing in
the mail and send it away it's oh
it's over it's going to become a brick
on
the new road to wherever you're headed
it's in your past it's what it was but
until you forgive yourself for what you
did
you're never gonna think you're worthy
of being loved and then you're gonna let
knucklehead hang around in a third
bedroom
sleep with them when you both get
exhausted and desperate or just need
human connection
and it's gonna be easier than dating
especially during covet and you're gonna
be able to lie to yourself and say
we're doing such a great job
co-parenting and what he needs to do is
get his own apartment get his own place
and still be
super present in his daughter's lives
that's his job not yours
okay yeah you know what i mean yes and i
try to make it my job or my
yeah i try to facilitate it you act
absolutely and you still will need to be
a
super connected facilitator right super
connected co-parent
but he needs to move on with his life
and take care of his new romantic world
and yours and if he says no no i don't
want to go
i've fallen back in love with you then
you all need to
zoom dir like do not pass go to a
marriage counselor
deal with the past infidelity and then
move on how long ago is that years
um this will be it's been five years ago
yeah done we're past it we're on
we're way past okay it's heal and or
separate
heal and or come closer together build
something
new together and something strong and
then we're done okay so i want you to
put that in a
envelope mail it to me and when it's
when you mail it never again
you're done with it it's over it's
something stupid you did in your past
and you're moving on
okay and then y'all are either going to
build something new or you are going to
scratch
the excavate that sucker and he's going
to be out so i would tell him tonight
this weekend hey listen we can't keep
playing house
we're divorced you need to get your own
place i need to move on with my life
i'm worthy of being loved um you're
worthy of being loved and we've already
determined it's not going to be between
the two of us
these girls are learning an unhealthy
model of what
this wacky weird arrangement looks like
we're going to co-parent awesome i'm
always going to love you you're always
going to love me
and then we're going to move on their
lives and we are going to be the best
co-parents to these daughters
in the whole wide world and when he
falls in love with somebody
she's gonna be a great um
influence around your daughters or she's
not coming around them and when you fall
in love with somebody
that guy's gonna be a great influence
around your daughters or he's not coming
around and right and we're all gonna do
this messy
gravelly uncomfortable walk together
but we're gonna make these we're gonna
pave this road with these bricks that
we're setting down we're gonna quit
carrying that crap around
thank you so much for that call alicia
let's go to andrew in
los angeles california andrew what's up
brother how are we doing
hey how's it going john all right man
hey
it is early out there you sound like
you're a cash brother you doing all
right
yeah no i haven't slept much so ah man i
hate that for you dude so what's up how
can i help
okay so um a little over two years
i'm 25 and a little over two years ago
uh
exactly three months after i got married
i
was working and i suffered an accident
where someone ran over my feet and
crushed my nerves
and left me disabled for the rest of my
life
i'm constantly in pain and
i guess what i wanted to ask is i've
been i've been diagnosed with like ptsd
and anxiety and i struggle really bad
with it
um constantly have episodes with
triggers
things that like such as
[Music]
the things that i got ran over with and
um would you get run over with
um someone used an electrical pallet
jack and bulldozed
a bunch of pallets over my feet and
yeah i mean i'm grateful i if i i fell
forward
if i had fallen back i would have fallen
into a
giant garbage compactor and probably
died yes
so are you able to walk now um i use a
wheelchair
and i use crutches okay i'm limited
okay so um yeah it's just it's just been
really hard on me and my wife my wife
has been
great but i constantly deal with like
nightmares night terrors waking up
screaming
waking her up freaking her out um having
anxiety attacks i mean i
i was doing pretty good there for a
while but even on sunday like i got
triggered and i just
just can't help it and i don't i don't
know how to work on it
man well i appreciate you i appreciate
your um
vulnerability here and saying this stuff
out loud okay
how have you um how have you tried to
move on what are some things you've
tried to do
um well i went through counseling for a
while okay
but i just i couldn't keep up with
paying for it so i'm in the middle of
doing social security i want to get back
on
to therapy and stuff like that but i
also i
come by three times a month out of my
own pocket
so i mean yeah it is what it is
you do what three times a month
i have a therapist come to my home i
work with me three times a month
okay so yeah um
so there's there's several things here
but i want to get right to the crux of
it okay so this happened how many
years ago a little over two years a
little over two years
like it's been such a such a
different such a crazy thing that's
happened because it's not like i was
worse from the beginning
i actually got worse with time and i
listened to the doctors and
with practice i got worse
unfortunately like they stuck needles in
my foot and
made me worse and pain got worse and
things like that it just
and even like all the while life was
crazy
my brother died from an overdose and i
had to push through my pain and
made my foot worse through all that
it's just i i'm not
i have a pretty high pain tolerance so
it is what it is but i do the best i can
i don't work anymore but it's just this
this constant fear of like my wife is
going to leave me and
these constant nightmares and
the constant nightmares of the accident
or
even somewhere it's like i want to kill
like my
my dreams like in my dreams i want to
kill myself yeah
and it's just like this this accident
has like
really made things hard yeah
so mentally like i've never experienced
it yeah man
um all right so i'm gonna be pretty
direct with you is that cool
yeah okay um
at some point whether that's today or
whether that's in a year
whether that's in three years or ten
years
at some point you're going to have to
come to terms with this is
your life and you have not yet
you are continuing to
live in the i can't believe this
happened part of this
and make no mistake this sucks you were
it
i hate that it happened to you you're a
victim of this thing
you were just standing there and your
business and somebody ran over your feet
it happened
and it's awful and it has altered the
way you will live your life
maybe even forever and then there's a
period at the end of that sentence
and the next sentence to be written is
you're sitting there with a pin in your
hand
and right now the sentence you are
choosing to write is
this sucks this is miserable she's
probably going to leave this sucks i
can't believe my brother died this is
miserable this sucks i hate it i hate it
i hate it
and all of that is true and
it's not doing one thing to make your
situation better
so when you are ready here's what you're
going to have to do
you're going to have to fully grieve
what was
you were a 23 year old guy you had just
gotten married it was party time you
were living it up
in southern california it was on it was
on it was on
and then suddenly it wasn't there's a
period at the end of that sentence
and you're going to have to be around
people who will grieve that with you
grief has to be seen by others or it
just goes inside
and then you're going to have to decide
who you're going to be on the back end
of this
you cannot at 25 years old cash out from
working
we have too much innate value in
contribution
and if you live a life where you aren't
contributing to
your community to your country to an a
job to your spouse
you will implode from the inside out and
you will drown everyone around you
yourself included
so you've got to be about what a meeting
am i going to make from what happened to
me
am i going to run an e-commerce business
am i going to work from home now that
covets happened anybody can work
anywhere for doing anything right
are you going to learn a whole new set
of skills and
use this time at home and crank it out
and be on disability a short time and
get back in the workforce
because i bet you've got a story to tell
and i bet you've got a bajillion people
to inspire
and i bet you can do just about anything
you want to because you've
you've persevered and you've overcome
this
right but at the end of the day you have
to ask yourself this one question
are you ready to move on and for some
reason you're not
i guess it's just been hard because
people constantly be telling
and and i know they're trying to be
positive but like oh you're gonna walk
you know one day you're not gonna hey
hey listen listen you you went right to
what other people are telling you
and i want to know what andrew's telling
andrew
i don't know i'm afraid i'm gonna be
stuck like this okay
so i was told i was gonna be permanently
handicapped the rest of my life
okay so here's the thing let's say that
you
are let's say you are permanently
handicapped the rest of you are in that
chair for the rest of your life
are you done 25 you're cashed out
no you're just going to give up
that's it no what are you going to do
brother
uh honestly i
before this happened i had that i had
dreams of
i met my wife in bible college and i
eventually wanted to go on and
work in a church and work eventually one
day
be a pastor okay all that came to a halt
when we left our church about a year ago
now we're
we're starting oh yeah we just started
going to a new one so kind of starting
over right now
so every single thing you just mentioned
you can do from your home
you can go to seminary from your house
you can
watch a bajillion youtube videos and
learn how to speak
you can create a podcast from your house
you can do home ministry people can come
to you you can go to them
if you're mobile
you can write you can start a blog
called living through paint you can do a
million things andrew but right now
you're blinded by
the voices of other people pumping you
up
you're blinded by the voices of other
people cutting you off at the knees
literally right so you got one group of
people saying oh you're going to be
playing tennis again soon and you've got
other people saying you will never get
out of that chair again
and you've got other people saying why
don't you just cut off your legs so
there you go
right so here's what here's the the
person who's nobody's listening to you
especially andrew and it's andrew
and you have to decide who goes in your
box
who are you going to listen to from this
point forward
nobody else gets a vote and then you
start with that pin in your hand brother
creating what today and tomorrow's going
to look like and it's going to hurt
and it's going to be frustrating and
there's going to be setbacks
and what's going to happen is you're
going to inch down that road
right like the tortoise in the hair
you're going to inch down that road and
everyone's going to be flying by you and
you're gonna keep inching and keep
inching
and keep writing and keep taking
seminary course after seminary course
and applying for jobs and not getting
them and keep applying and reaching out
and getting a coaching certificate
and and and and along the way
you're going to talk to your wife and be
vulnerable and say hey today kind of
sucks and then when days don't suck
you're going to say
how can i honor and love you because
you're not going to keep
leaning on these on these emotional
crutches you got your physical crutches
you're not going to keep leaning back
like i know honey but two years ago
you're gonna say cool let's figure this
out and when you hurt
you're gonna keep trying and you're
gonna listen to doctors yeah
okay some doctors screwed up you go to
the next one right
find online those um body movement
coaches and begin to get some
flexibility back in your hips and your
knees
right whatever it takes because here's
the alternative andrew
just sitting in the chair man
just sitting in the chair
i've i've been working on that been
pushing myself to do
things more physically lately i mean
last year i was like
completely like confined to the chair
now i've been
using my crutches sometimes even going
out dressed with crutches
so you're seeing a little bit of
movement right the tortoise is slowly
starting to
okay there you go brother but hey you're
talking
you're talking about physical stuff tell
me about your soul man
it's like that's where i'm struggling
like i i can't control like the
nightmares that i have
i can't control i mean like i have
sleeping aids but i don't like to take
them because they make me feel
hungover pretty much okay so here's the
deal man
listen listen ptsd anxiety depression
those are all alarms
that tell you that your body's setting
off
that this thing is still happening that
you aren't safe you don't have a
community around you
right in these nightmares these loops
there are some pretty clear and
relatively simple ways to stop those
nightmares
okay but it caught it it means you have
to be highly intentional in the daytime
so when you have this nightmare i want
you to wake up and write it down
it takes the power away from it when you
put it on a piece of paper
during the day i want you to write down
the most recurring nightmare
right the one that you are that that
that forklift is coming right at you
that front end loader is coming right at
you
right and what i want you to do is i
want you to write it down but this time
i want you to change the ending
that it misses right that somebody
blows the whistle and the whole thing
stops and you're safe and you walk away
i want you to write that down on a piece
of paper and then i want you to
to read it a couple of times a day a
couple of times a day
and what's going to happen is your
nightmares are going to be released your
body is going to go
andrew's back in charge because right
now andrew's not in charge man you
cashed out
and that's okay i understand you were
you suffered a bad trauma
and so what your body is trying to do is
take care of andrew because andrew's not
taking care of andrew
and so every scary thing in the world
it's setting off every alarm you got
when you're asleep when you're awake
when you're when you're not paying
attention it sets off your anxiety when
your anxiety is up it
it wants you just to get under the
covers and sleep right with that
depression
it is trying to take care of you because
andrew is not online and you got to
bring andrew back online
and that means you got to grieve what
happened decide there's a period at the
end of that sentence it happened
and now what is andrew going to be about
in the future who is andrew gonna be
and that is an emotional psychological
spiritual exercise where every day
you're writing down a gratitude journal
every day you're writing you're here's
who i'm gonna be today
and then you're gonna be really graceful
with yourself you're gonna have a
community of people with you
who's walking this with you man um
my wife and then i just uh i just had
some
a couple of my friends just come back
from the military
that's awesome and uh they uh they
didn't really know how bad things were
until we sat down and talked and awesome
now they're
they're they're trying to be there for
me and they check up on me now
so once hey once a week once a week
you're going to have a group called
andy's army and y'all going to get
together for
drinks or hanging out or having coffee
or tea whatever it is y'all do you're
gonna do it once a week
and you're not always gonna talk about
the accident you're gonna talk about
what's going on each other's lives and
your marriages and whatever
and listen sitting there every day
wondering if she's gonna leave you if
she's to leave you is going to certify
one thing she's probably going to leave
you
instead of it's it's anticipatory
anxiety
right you are projecting a fear into the
future and you are worrying about it now
as though it's happening
i want to hear you like every time that
i have
thought about this she reassures me that
that's not gonna happen
okay there's no indication that that
would happen in real life it's just like
a subconscious fear that i've i've had
since back with it yeah and here's the
deal man your
your body has experienced the worst and
so it is mining any possible future
worst and trying to protect you from it
now
and what it's going to do is drown
everybody around you
so instead of worrying about when that
thought pops in your head she's going to
leave you i want you to say out loud
nope she's here for good and
i'm gonna be an incredible partner i'm
gonna be a great husband
and you and her are gonna already have
talked about these things y'all are
gonna do together
right so you're talking about being a
husband talking about possibly being a
dad
talking about getting back into the
workforce being somebody who leads other
people
all of this is beautiful and the ptsd
the anxiety the depression
listen your body is working perfectly it
is trying to take care of you and
protect you
it is trying to care for you because you
got hurt bad
and so what you have to do is let your
body know let your wife know
let your buddies who just got back from
the army who are going to start coming
over your house once a week to hang out
let everybody know andrew's coming back
online
and that starts with picking up that pen
and writing the next chapter of your
story
and it's going to hurt and it's going to
suck and you've got to have people with
you
and you're going to keep writing and
you're going to keep writing and there's
going to be weeks
that you get buried and you write
nothing and then you're going to pick
that pin back up and you're going to
write a gratitude journal again
you're going to write your affirmations
again you're going to keep working on
your physical body you're going to keep
working on your head you're going to
read
books you're going to take online
classes you're going to contribute
to something and you're going to decide
at 25 i'm not cashing out and to you to
those y'all listening to this
at 35 at 55 at 75 i'm not cashing out
life is made up of tragedy and trauma
and ugliness and brokenness and
accidents
and somebody treating you but it's
that's that's life
and that's why we have other people in
our lives that's why we
try to take care of ourselves and then
we got that pin that lonely lonely pen
to write the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing
andrew i believe in you and as you walk
through this i want you to keep in touch
with us
as we keep going all right all right
andrew thank you so much for that call
hey listen tomorrow i'm gonna go spend
two hours with a counselor
my wife she's a counselor everybody i
know i recommend
during this season of grief during the
season of change transition whatever's
going on go see a professional counselor
but listen
not everybody can get there people got
mobility challenges it's expensive
wait lists across the country are weeks
and months long
so here's what i did i partnered with
better help
an online counseling program they've got
licensed counselors that will talk to
you with video chat
on the phone even text chat i've never
even heard of text chat therapy
but they've got it with licensed
professionals
listen go to betterhelp.com deloney for
10 percent off your first month
it is cheaper than in-person therapy and
instead of six months wait list or six
weeks waitlist whatever
if you get in touch with them within 48
hours somebody will reach out and talk
to you
betterhelp.com 10 off
for real counseling right now when you
need it
where you need it you're worth getting
well
all right let's take one more call let's
go to nicki in seattle
nikki what's going on hi dr john thank
you so much for taking my call
you bet thanks for calling how are you
i'm good how are you
we are having a blast figuring it out
one
caller at a time i guess i'm still
figuring out what i'm even doing with my
life nikki so we'll get there right
so hey how can i help you what's going
on
so my boyfriend and i have been together
for six years
and we have two babies together
we have a step we have a seven month old
and a two-year-old
so you're in it now huh yeah a minute
do you even hey do you even know what
day it is
i i actually don't i know it's somewhere
in april
i love that okay all right so
you have a two-year-old and a seven
month old you don't know what day it is
and i can only guess where this is going
you've been dating this guy for
six years yeah and then what
well so he kind of
so we live together you know we we play
house as dave calls it
okay and he has a hard time with me
i guess i should say i have a hard time
keeping up with
his kind of expectations
um so he wants me to exercise more and
to get my body back to the way it was
um but i feel i feel so overwhelmed
but hey just uh just a quick thing does
he know that you have a seven month old
and a two-year-old i think he's picked
that up by now i think i think he might
pick that up myself okay so i
i i'm trying to wrap my head around this
walk me through how that actual
conversation takes place
so he sees you breastfeeding a kid and
there's a two-year-old just screaming
and you have dinner cooking
and he looks at you and goes yeah this
body is not cutting it you're gonna have
to fix it like
how does that even happen
he'll get home from work and he'll be
like so did you do your exercise bike
today
gosh what i say no i did not do my
exercise bike today
now dr john i'm dealing with a guy
who has the mindset of jocko
i know but listen i do too i love jocko
i'm gonna do a speaking engagement with
him in a few weeks
i love him and you know what i didn't
never ever did
look at my wife without holding a seven
month old and be like so how'd your
workout go today babe
you know never you know why because i
have a soul
and i actually care about human beings
right that like i don't care
jocko wouldn't do that to his own wife
and he's got multiple he's got four or
five kids right
god almighty so
i always want to try to find the soul in
somebody what they're trying to trying
to be helpful
is
and my body's not even that bad i've
lost 70 pounds no
listen nikki this has nothing to do with
your body i'm trying to get to a place
where i can empathize with this guy
before i just hang up on you and i call
him directly
so that's that's not even our main
problem though
oh sweet we'll continue nikki go ahead
um so he's
he thinks i don't keep the house clean
enough oh gosh
nikki listen and to where the point he
wants to kick me out
hey listen go ba
take both of those kids and go i know
i can't do that though hey listen
go
this guy's not worthy of another second
of your love
and your time and your affection did i
try
i try but it's just so much in a day he
says i spend too much time on
social media like i get that but i just
i don't have the motivation right now to
do any of anything
yeah no have you left before
yeah i i i just came back like a week
ago or
yeah about a week ago so you moved out
okay so how was that time away
it was very good um it's it's hard you
know living somewhere else
yeah why'd you come back two little
monsters
um well i just i want i missed him
and i want my kids to be around their
dad
hey i don't want my kids around a guy
like that
i don't want my kids around a guy like
that i don't want to like women
i don't want my friend nikki around a
guy like that
now here's the thing he may understand
that exercise especially for folks
with postpartum is really good for you
he may understand that scrolling social
media
is not good for you right and he's right
on both of those things
but he also needs to know that beating
up on
a struggling mom of two tiny little
babies
clear there's other things going on in
your relationship
clearly and if he is somebody who has
chosen not to commit to you
after six years and two kids together
and now he's putting ultimatums on you
because he wants his old life back
and it's your job to get that old life
back for him
then he's not somebody that's going to
be there long term for you
okay do you hear them you hear what i'm
saying
yeah you know i'm right aren't i
you are right and i know my mind is like
you know if he's not willing to marry me
you know and not be like well maybe if
you because he says this is like
this is the job interview and if i want
the reason why
wait six years and two kids and you're
interviewing
yeah i know nikki
you know who wouldn't put up with that
crap jocko
and i won't either you're worth more
than that
are you struggling right now yes
is exercise i tell them it's just
a season we're in the thick of this so
we're in the thick of this right now
and it's just it's like it's in one ear
not the other doesn't care
just it's like the only thing he sees is
the house and the house is a little
messy we've got dishes and we've got
dirty laundry and there's toys
everywhere and that's all he sees i
swear that's all he sees
and so one of jocko's core tenants is
when you see a challenge
fix it yeah and what every husband
who's got a wife with a two-year-old and
a seven month old
in the house should do is step up and
help with the dishes
for crying out loud and the vacuuming
and the laundry and i don't care how
many jobs you're working i don't care
how busy you don't care how tired you
are
as you mentioned you're in a season when
it's winter
everybody puts on a jacket everybody
has to de-ice the driveway everybody has
to do different things in winter
because it's winter and when you have a
two-year-old and a seven month old
everything feels a little bit heavy is
that right
oh yeah okay and now listen
i will tell you in a more gentle way you
will never go wrong
putting those kids in a double stroller
and going for a long walk ever
you will never go wrong by being on your
phone less
right and you know that right oh yeah
you'll never go wrong by by um
making a list of the things that you
need to do in a day
and really leaning into them to use
jocko language to crush those things on
that list
however big or small they are and
sometimes they're a small
for a mom with a seven month old and a
two-year-old sometimes it's as small as
i'm gonna make the bed i'm gonna take a
shower
and i'm going to fill in the blank i'm
gonna do one thing around here
right and you're going to sit down with
him and you're all going to plan that
out
and i would recommend doing it to the
day but if he said the words to you this
is a job interview
i want i want you to walk out of the job
interview
because you don't want to work there you
know what i mean
you don't want to work there and that is
scary and that is terrifying
and that is frustrating that guy does
not deserve you
okay you don't deserve
to be interviewing after six years in
kids i know
i i i i completely agree okay so what's
stopping you
what what's stopping you i don't want a
broken family
it is broken
it is you running around with duct tape
doesn't make your tile floor not
cracked yeah
and what's happening is these these two
little kids are abs are figuring out wow
this is how
this is how parents act
this is how two people who play house
and love each other act
does they treat each other yeah yeah
you know what i mean i i get it i
i get it this is how a grown man
treats the wife of his two little babies
you know yeah and that's that's what i'm
afraid of
don't be afraid of it because when you
say i'm afraid of it that's like saying
a bear might come
this has come it is at your door it is
in your home
okay gosh i know i know so when when he
when you were off at your dad's house
was he calling you saying hey come home
come home i'm sorry
he well let's let's
let's make note that there was not any
i'm sorry thrown into this at all okay
um he said he
wanted to but he didn't want to seem
desperate and i'm like what we're not
dating like we're not like at the
beginning of our relationship
you don't have to play it cool i can't
date a robot anymore
i need to know like feelings i need to
hear these
these feelings i don't want to be
desperate
i know i don't want to seem desperate
and i was like what do you mean
desperate like if your wife and your two
babies leave your house
that is the definition of desperate
and it was so funny i got it oh god it
was so funny he called me because
he was like hey the lights are out how
do you pay the electric bill
your lights got cut off no
we did i didn't pay it in time and so he
was like hey could you pay this for me
i mean using his card and stuff and he
pays for it but he didn't know how to
so like i think that's a little
desperate honey okay so here's the deal
nikki here's what i want you to do in
all seriousness
and i know that you are laughing to keep
this overwhelming tide of grief to come
over you is that fair yeah
definitely okay so i want you
to today call a
local counselor in your area and set up
an appointment for just you
okay okay spend whatever you got to
spend for child care
call whoever you got to call um if you
got to drop them off at your dad's house
drop them off at your dad's house
but i want you to go see somebody and i
want you to lay out
here's what's happening and if you want
to try
and save this relationship because they
save your marriage but it's not even one
um you have a daughter
i have two sons two sons okay so one of
your sons comes home
in 22 years 23 years 24 years
and says hey mom you know susan i've
been dating for six years
we're having a second kid and i told her
this is gonna be a great try out for her
to see if she's gonna be the one we're
sticking around
what would your response to that boy be
i'd be so mad at him
that's right that's right
yeah yep okay and i want you to treat
yourself
with that same level of care i want you
to treat those babies that same level of
care
my deepest wish is that your husband
goes what am i doing
or your boyfriend does goes what am i
doing and he snaps out of it
okay and maybe he's misreading jocko
and misreading the understanding of what
that guy talks about
but the root of what he talks about is
ownership
responsibility accomplishing a mission
right not berating a
exhausted frustrated um postpartum
mother of their two babies
okay into every guy out there listening
to this
stop stop
you want your wife to get off social
media give her a place worthy of being
off social media for
you and a wife who's not so exhausted
all the time pick up the crap around the
house
sit down and have that conversation with
her and say how can i honor you today
and i know you're off making the money i
know you're off
doing your work blah blah blah whatever
cool
you know you're not doing dragging
around two little kids
my wife's been out of town for a few
days and i've had the kids at my house
coming into work is a blessing and a
gift in a safe safe quiet place
and it's been like three days
not day after day after day after year
after year nikki i'm so sorry this is
happening to you and i'm sorry to
tell you this but you know
i'm not telling anything new right right
yeah is your dad in your corner is your
mom in your corner
definitely okay so i want you to lean on
them but today i want you to
go make an appointment with a counselor
and start getting the help and care that
you need
and either come up with a
a if then if now if not now
then conversation with your boyfriend
a practice conversation or an exit
strategy
sooner rather than later you are not on
a job interview
you are not trying out for this guy's
love
you're better than that you got more
than that
husbands create a home for your wives so
they don't want to be on social media
they want to be with you
create an environment where they've got
space to go exercise and move their
bodies
into walk because there's not 40 other
things that you've given them to do or
they feel
obligated to do in this space so they
don't even have time to take care of
themselves
create a world where your partner's got
space
man i i hate that for you nicki i'm
heartbroken for you
she's louise i don't even know how to
end this show man um
no you know what you're gonna end this
with strength just like i told the
caller earlier
you've got the pen now there's appeared
in that sentence when he said i don't
appear desperate
cool you are desperate you're at the end
of your rope and now you got a pen you
get to write what happens next
and i want you to write i matter my kids
matter
i'm worthy of being loved i'm worthy
being in a situation where
i'm not trying out where i am fully
known and fully loved
and i'm gonna start taking the next step
to get there it's a teeny tiny
frustrating
collapsing step but i'm going to get
there i'm going to take the next one i'm
going to lean on my dad i'm going to my
mom i'll lean on my counselor i'm going
to lean on my friends in my community
because this guy said he won't be there
not until i passed the tryout
which is i guess is six years and two
kids later
but you're gonna be a fierce bad man
pajama nicki
and we're all rooting for you let me
know how that conversation goes let me
know how connecting with that counselor
goes
gentlemen be better i'm saying this to
myself i gotta be better too but we
gotta be better
we gotta be better than that and if we
got friends in our lives that
talk that crap to their wives to their
girlfriends we gotta be willing to step
up and say no
absolutely not absolutely not it's not
funny it's not a joke it's not
good bro nope be better than that
we got to hold ourselves accountable
gentlemen
starting yesterday all right so as i
wrap up today's show
um let's see here
you know what we're just gonna go
straight here because
when things get bleak and heavy and they
lay on your soul
sometimes you just gotta go back
to a little bit of screamo music a
little bit of dramatic screamo music
where i got enough screamo that they
needed to add a piano
this album by my chemical romance i
loved this song welcome to the black
parade
and it was on the album the black parade
and it goes like this
it's so dramatic it's so good when i was
a young boy
my father took me into the city to see a
marching band he said son when you grow
up will you be the savior of the broken
the beaten and the damned
he said will you defeat them your demons
and all the non-believers
the plans that they have made because
one day i'll leave you
a phantom to lead you in the summer to
join the black parade
sometimes i get the feeling she's
watching over me and other times i feel
like i should go
and through it all the rise and fall the
bodies in the streets and when you're
gone we all want you to know
we'll carry on we'll carry on and though
you're dead and gone believe me
your memory will carry on hey dude go
listen to
welcome to the black parade this song
will make your heart swell
you might roll your eyes but it's good
and it gets in your soul
especially the piano part huh i love you
some of my chemical romance this has
been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you